[Musique]
le festival tanjazz des théâtres est
désormais un rendez vous habituel
cette année encore plus le jazz sera
partout grâce à un partenariat avec la
mairie de saint paul
mais c'est sans aucun doute au théâtre
plein air que les notes résonneront le
plus avec des artistes d'ici et
d'ailleurs
c'est une musique jazz qui est très
empreinte de ses racines africaines
puisqu'il y aura jean marie barré le
fabio marivin et aussi
[Musique]
le crio est en exposition extérieure
nous aurons chamakh a lancé store qui
c'est un musicien anglais vient avec une
proposition avec des musiciens
sud-africains yaron herman et michel
portal sur une musique hyper virtuose et
pour terminer les amazones d'afrique qui
sera un groupe de femmes d'afrique de
l'ouest
un festival qui sera également présent
dans les collèges prof ja pinpin le 7
sauf au nist de jazz sera accompagné de
la chanteuse joan arrêt là et du
pianiste henri rault miniac six collèges
auront le privilège de découvrir
l'histoire du jazz
la culture est vecteur de promotion quoi
notre jeunesse
si on veut que nos jeunes réussissent à
l'école eh bien il faut lui a donné tous
les moyens justement pour atteindre cet
objectif et ça passe par un
développement culturel
on se rend compte que les élèves à
partir du moment où on leur montre de
qualités ils sont tout à fait présent et
bien raconter des anecdotes à chaque
fois mais dans la maille l'année
dernière quand on est allé dans les
collèges
à la fin j'ai lu marwijk avait jamais
entendu de dja de sa vie est d'arriver
en glissant quand jean monsieur les
affaires des gagnants est ce que vous
pouvez gala ce samedi souple et voilà
les c'est quelqu'un qui avait osé braver
sa peur pour venir demander une place
pour venir par un concert de jazz de la
saison et grande nouveauté cette année
le jazeera aussi du côté des groupes
d'habitations situées à plateau caillou
et à st paul's
[Musique]